the Amazon manatee lives in fresh water
along the river of the same name it's
tributaries and nearby lagoons it can
weigh more than 400 kilos and grow to
almost 3 meters in length even so many
people here have never spotted one in
the wild el manatee is the manatee is
the biggest species of mammal in the
amazon basin but it's probably the least
well-known when we started working here
80% of the people in Iquitos had never
heard of the creature
Nakano see Adele existence iya desta
speci
this stretch of the Amazon in Peru looks
idyllic but there are environmental
problems here too
[Music]
and many species are under threat
manatees are classified as a vulnerable
species that's one step before and
dangered no Saba quantal money we don't
know how many Amazon manatees there are
here it's really hard to determine the
number because the water is so murky
elsewhere it's easier you just fly over
the area in a little plane and can just
see how many manatees there are along
the banks and Shores what we do know is
that in many places people used to see
manatees but don't anymore and every
year there are more and more places
where they are no longer to be seen the
Amazon Rescue Center in Iquitos looks
after several species of animal and it
may be the world's only nursery for
manatees preparing them for a future in
the wild the babies have to be bottle
fed every two hours until they're 2
years old
they're lactose intolerant so they're
given special milk imported from the US
bringing up baby can cost more than
$10,000 a year manatees are under threat
for several reasons the ban on hunting
them isn't always observed their meat is
considered a delicacy some get trapped
in fishing nets and drown when they
can't come to the surface to breathe
another problem is that people like to
keep manatee babies as pets because
they're so cute cuando ba sometimes
babies get caught in fishing nets and
are then taken home people keep them in
their fish pond or in a tank but under
these conditions the little ones always
die manatees have no natural enemies
apart from human beings they're trusting
creatures and don't shy away from people
which makes it all the easier to hunt
them for their meat skin and oil when
they come up to breathe a hunter will
stick two plugs of wood up their
nostrils it's an extremely cruel way to
kill such a noble creature which is so
important for nature
importante para Luna to release manatees
do indeed fulfill an important function
in the environment their vegetarian and
have to consume huge amounts of aquatic
plants as they're not very nutritious up
to 70 kilograms a day they're grazing
helps clear waterways and lagoons
[Music]
manatees eat aquatic plants like this
wama or water lettuce and other plants
that grow on the surface in areas where
manatees have been killed off the plants
just grow and grow and spread across the
water surface the light of the Sun can't
enter the water and that reduces the
growth of plankton which affects the
entire food chain and reduces the number
of fish that in turn affect the people
living along the Amazon they have fewer
fish to eat and can't even go fishing if
the water surface is overgrown it's a
real problem
aquatic plants on the waterways and
lagoons of the Amazon are spreading even
to other countries such as Colombia
where there are no hungry manatees keen
to eat them and the water hyacinth for
example is toxic to some of the animals
living there horses and cattle can eat
this plant but there simply aren't
enough of them to control the spread
back at the Amazon rescue center in
Iquitos there's been an unexpected but
very happy development every six months
we gather in the manatees to weigh them
before we release them we were totally
surprised to find two babies among them
in the pre-release pool that's amazing
news for Peru because it's the first
time that manatees had offspring in
captivity the center has so far
rehabilitated 25 manatees every release
is a complicated procedure and a big
event the staff and friends all join in
the manatees are taken to a suitable
location before the final farewell the
lagoons and rivers are interconnected so
manatees stand a good chance of meeting
fellow creatures in the wild the efforts
of the devoted team at the rescue center
are contributing to the well-being of
the adorable animals and the
stabilization of the ecosystem
[Music]